the first part of the question is
defining who the scholars are
what has happened is there are a
brothers like you said there's no doubt
that our Dean encourages us to take from
the other man and the lost kind of
dollar says in the Quran such an
addiction including some light on the
moon asked the people of knowledge if
you don't know so there are a lot of
things about our religion that we don't
know is our obligation at that point if
we're not from the people of ish D had
or from the students of knowledge who
can go back and study the issues for
themselves you have to go to somebody
whose knowledge you respect whose God
consciousness and tough where you
respect and you go to them and you ask
them ok oh the concept and the
promissory some has I mean many I had
need to talk about the virtue of the
scholars this is something that is
undeniable I would hope that no Muslim
denies the virtue of the scholars fee
the problem is is when we get a group of
people who champion that but then they
define for everybody else who the
scholars are so the scholars are the
people who they have a connection with
and the point is to monopolize
authenticity of dower so no dower
is authentic unless we've sanctioned it
and we sanction it we have that ability
to sanction we are the accrediting body
that sanctions whether or not this dower
is correct or not we are the accrediting
body because we have been given that
authority by the scholars well the
question is who gave you the right to
determine for the people in the West
that these are the scholars ok this is
the first question is a very important
point here and it's not to deny the
scholarship of the ones that they are
saying are scholars because they may or
may not be that's not really my issue
here why are they the only scholars
we can refer to and if we go outside of
those four or five who they have
determined and declared to be the
scholars then we're not going back to
the right scholars or whatever they
situation may be so I mean that the
first part of the logic that's flawed is
that they are trying to tell us who the
scholars are when in fact the scholars
of Islam have recognized many more
people and some of them more prominently
than the ones that they have set up to
be scholars in the West without going
into any names all right so that's the
first that's the first thing that has to
be dealt with the second thing is that
there's almost a degree of self-hate
that is involved in that or a lack of
self-worth if we look at it every other
country Jannik besides of gullible
Western brothers every other country has
their own scholars they may not be on
the level of the scholars here who have
dedicated their entire lives to the
study of its land but if you go to
Nigeria there are scholars if you go to
Senegal there are scholars if you go to
Pakistan
there's scholars India there's God so on
and so forth right so we have gotten to
the point that we can't even recognize
our own scholarship that there may
perhaps be people in the United States
of America who can answer a large amount
of the questions that we have and it
doesn't mean that they're going to be
able to answer every question so that
they're from the key bottom of the mat
or to the end of it but that's not the
condition that a la sfera gotta lay down
on the Quran or from the Sunnah of the
Prophet is on a person and the person
needs to know about what they're talking
about doesn't mean they have to be from
the keyboard or the man where they are
what we would call encyclopedic and
their knowledge right no but if you ask
them about Islamic finance they can
answer that if you ask them about bad
debt then this person can answer that
but what's happened is we've denied our
own scholarship you know in the name of
propping up these these other scholars
or
in the name of respecting these other
scholars and so as such you know we turn
our backs on the fact that hey maybe we
need to be further supporting our own
scholars and again scholarship is of
different levels and maybe this person
is not a scholar but he's a solid
student of knowledge who can deal with
this particular you know contemporary
issue that has come up or we had bodies
of scholars because we have and in the
West we have certain bodies of scholars
who when they get together I think that
their scholarship is noteworthy it's
something that should it means to be
taken into consideration and we
shouldn't just ignore the fact you know
that we do have some people of knowledge
among us and the West who can help deal
with some of these issues so I think
that that that diversion tactic that is
used is because it is profitable to the
people who use it and I'm not saying
that everywhere I'm not I'm not talking
about intention here that every single
person that says hey you need to follow
follow the scholars follow scholars that
this is their that this is their idea
that they're looking for something
outside of what they really believe is
the truth but I'm keenly aware that
there are some that definitely profit
from the fact that they seem to have
this monopoly on what is authentic our